Aaron Rodgers may not like the product
of the Packers draft that was Peters
first big takeaway to slap in the face
that Aaron Rodgers absorbed and I
mentioned that because yesterday Bob him
again who covered the Packers for 38
years and has more recently been writing
for the athletic he had this quote that
just slapped me in the face when I read
it regarding the decision to draft
Jordan Love in Green Bay in round one
Trading up to get him and then otherwise
loading up the running game after that
public niceties aside McGinn rights
my sense is Matt Lafleur the coach of
the Packers simply has had enough of
Aaron Rodgers Act and wanted to change
the narrative with a first-round talent
on the roster in Jordan love the Packers
would gain leverage with their Imperial
quarterback and his passive aggressive
style if the Packers do indeed want to
become a running team next season they
surely wouldn't want Rodgers rocking the
boat and becoming even more difficult to
coach I mean there's a lot in there that
yeah we could probably spend a segment
on each sentence in that paragraph Peter
yeah but you know I mean McGinn covered
the team for 38 years and McGinn still
knows that team better than any other
team I mean there's stuff there that
surprised me because I thought Aaron
Rodgers was happy last year I thought
the passive-aggressive stuff ended when
Mike McCarthy got fired he went on and
on after they lost to the 49ers in the
NFC Championship game about how he loves
football again with all these players
who have come in and helped with the
leadership and the players are empowered
undermount Lafleur what gives Peter Mike
the really interesting thing out of that
and obviously I have more respect for
Bob McGann than any beat writer in the
country he's unbelievably good but the
biggest deal in in all of what he said
and now the stuff that's come bubbling
beneath the surface is that you know
last year basically Matt Lafleur and
Aaron Rodgers had sort of I don't even
want to call it a truce because I don't
think it came from any place of anger or
defiance or anything like that but Aaron
Rodgers
gonna get to change place and change a
lot of place and I will go back in time
right now Mike and everybody says with
Drew Bledsoe and Tom Brady that the real
story behind that was that well you know
Bledsoe got hurt because he was hit and
plowed into the sideline by Moe Lewis of
the Jets and had a life-threatening
life-threatening internal injuries and
what we now know about that is Bill
Belichick was already sick and so was
charlie weis at the time the offensive
coordinator
I'm not saying sick of how often Drew
Bledsoe change plays at the line of
scrimmage but I think Belichick
basically felt at the time that hey look
we work all week on doing this stuff and
now you're changing all these plays why
are we doing that and I and again I want
to find out I want to know how many
plays last year did Aaron Rodgers
actually change from Matt Lafleur's
original call and he's got a lot of
freedom but did that freedom sort of
backfire on him now we're gonna find
that out pretty soon but that freedom
that Aaron Rodgers had I now really
wonder whether he took that freedom too
far well maybe he did maybe he did take
it too far but what's gonna stop him now
I mean they better be careful you know
to a degree here I you know they've been
powered him here for the next two years
- cuz he could just be like hey screw
all of you looks like you want to
replace me oh you wanted to run that 96
Tower King running play forget it I like
to throw a slant over here Davante Adams
so you know I think that's the
interesting aspect of all this you know
and I don't really know what Green Bay's
thought was I mean obviously they're
planning for the future you know do I
think Matt Lafleur you know was a little
taken aback by last year by the fact
that you know he made some comments
during the season I was going back
looking at a few things last night where
he talked about like he felt weird in
the fourth quarter cuz he wasn't doing
anything because he basically just went
okay Rogers you you take over
I don't think Matt
fleurs the type of person that's like
man I can't believe you know Rogers took
away my power in the fourth quarter
I'm going to take it back I don't think
he's that type of guy I've been around
him before I do think he was genuine and
his you know love affair that Rodgers
did bring so much to the offense last
year so I'm not so sure I can get behind
all the things in that report and you
know I you know dime again I know as an
unbelievable writer and he's awesome and
I'm not trying to you know say he's
lying or anything like that but I just
don't know what that thought process is
right now and I guess my big thing is
Green Bay better be very careful about
how they approach this or they're gonna
really lose control of this guy and
he'll do whatever the hell he wants well
done again the former White House
Counsel may indeed be a great writer Bob
McGann also is here's the thing Peter
Peter you hit the nail on the head
because last year it was that column
from Mike silver your former colleague
at Sports Illustrated now at NFL media
who tapped into that the audible thing
is Matt Lafleur called it the tension
that existed between the LeFleur offense
and Aaron Rodgers wanting to have the
freedom at the line of scrimmage to not
have his hands tied by this plan to have
two plays called in the huddle and then
the quarterback based upon a
predetermined set of factors would
determine at the line of scrimmage which
one to use he doesn't even have
discretion he has to make a decision
based on what he sees not what he thinks
is going to work that ultimately swung
in Aaron Rodgers favor and he ended up
with the full freedom to change the play
whenever he want I spoke to Matt Lafleur
after they beat the Pat of the Bears in
December and he said I have full trust
in Aaron Rodgers there was a touchdown
early in the game on a 4th and 4 play
from the Chicago 29 where Rodgers
changed the play and Lafleur was like
what the hell is he doing and he scored
so it's like that's fine but Peter I
still think that at some level it does
create tension within the coach like
there's
system that I use there's a an attack
that I have honed that helped me get
this job at some point I'd kind of like
to use it and I don't know how actively
they try to rein Aaron Rodgers in or
Chris like you say whether it will even
work because I don't think it will work
I think the next year or two is going to
be very bumpy and very rocky in Green
Bay
until they get to the point where the
cap hit won't be devastating to move on
from Aaron Rodgers but but Peter III
really you know I thought what was there
last summer had been resolved but
reading what Bob McGann wrote and
hearing your reaction to it it really
makes me think it hasn't been resolved
it was just kind of tucked under the
covers to be dealt with another day
we'll see Mike you know Chris is right
it's gonna be a very interesting time
plus I mean what's what is unfortunate
in my opinion for the Packers is that
they're not going to be able to get
together much this offseason
who knows Aaron Rodgers might not shake
Jordan love's hand until August 20th you
know I and and and they might not get
together so we don't know exactly what
is going to happen and how things are
going to change two points though Mike
didn't you find it very interesting and
I talked to Brian gudykunst on Sunday
but didn't you find it very interesting
that Brian gudykunst went out of his way
at his post draft remarks to basically
say we want to run the ball we want to
be you know we're gonna it sounded very
much like he was saying you know instead
of being 60/40 pass we're gonna be 50/50
now or or or something like that or
that's what we want to do that's the
first thing and that's why drafting a
Jay Dylan which to me I don't know you
got two running backs that are pretty
good right now you desperately need a
wide receiver compliment to Davante
Adams that's I keep coming back to that
I'll come back to it until the Green Bay
Packers play a football game and blow
somebody out with you know vol D
scantling and equina Mia st. Browne and
all that and and the Packers say those
guys are gonna be good play
okay let's see but my biggest issue now
is six years in a row six years the
Green Bay Packers have not drafted a
wide receiver in the first three rounds
and they have not spent significant
money on a wide receiver and free agency
if you're Aaron Rodgers what are you
thinking right now yeah well I mean I'm
with you I don't understand what Green
Bay's thinking
I mean hey you're talking about the wide
receivers Peter King and I'm with you
that's confusing I mean one you know I
think you could argue Aaron Rodgers has
been like the greatest one-man band in
football the last eight or nine years
maybe until the last few years with
Russell Wilson but it's been a lot of
underwhelming receivers and offensive
weapons that man is there a lot of
pressure on Aaron Rodgers on a
week-to-week basis that was the thing
that's always bothered me it bothered me
about when Mike home-brewed was there
you know it bothered me again last year
there was moments where you just go man
can can we just find somebody that can
maybe catch a slant run for 70 yards
does it always have to be Rodgers
dissecting a team down the field and
having to make throws that nobody else
can make like we saw in the Seattle
Seahawks playoff game or many other
examples so you know and the other thing
I'll say too here is you know with the
offensive thing III just III just don't
know you know again what I want to say
is Matt Lafleur who I have respect for
okay and I still think probably got this
job
a little early or before he really
deserved it for lack of a better way to
say it
I mean his year as an offensive
coordinator with the Tennessee Titans
they were what 27th or 29th and football
on offense and when you apply for the
Green Bay Packer job you have to know
what you're applying for so I would
think Green Bay knew and Matt Lafleur
would know what they're going to get
when you're going there okay yeah we're
gonna get the coach one of the greatest
quarterbacks we've ever seen but also a
quarterback that we know yes changes
changes has always had free rein
throughout his career he wasn't just
gonna give that up and I think Matt
Lafleur would have known that and was so
successful in so many moments last year
and I still think with
under the center in big moments the
green bag can pound the table and say we
want to run the ball all we want when it
comes down to third and two in a big
moment of the game Aaron Rodgers gonna
go hey I like my old line I like Aaron
Jones but I trust my right arm and
Davante Adams more so I'm going to throw
the ball here and I don't think that's
gonna change until they get rid of
Rodgers and that's where it's gonna get
very interesting here in the next year
or two for me and then we have to take a
break I think it comes down to the old
cliche if you can't beat them join them
and when we saw what happened to Packers
when they went to San Francisco in
January and got blown off the field they
got blown off the field not by a passing
game they got blown off the field by a
running game and like in the aftermath
of that that expertly designed Kyle
Shanahan attack where Mike Lafleur is an
assistant coach he's a passing game
coordinator who had nothing to
coordinate that game because they ran
the ball ran the ball ran the ball down
the throats of the Green Bay Packers
instead of beefing up the run defense
instead of beefing up the passing game
right Mike wants his own running game
that he can now trot out and he can be
the genius like Kyle Shanahan who
designs these runs and wears a defense
down and beats a team that way and if it
means Aaron Rodgers gets thrown
overboard at some point in the next
couple of years so be it
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports